o'clock I will open up today's public
hearings first hearing to be um House
Bill 1439 relative vehicle registration
reciprocal toll collection enforcement
agreements and I would like to recognize
the
representative comea please
present your testimony and and welcome
to public
works thank you Mr chair and thank you
members of the committee for the record
I'm representative coma representing
belnap
7 the reason I'm bringing this bill
forward is that I have a
constituency
um that has had issues with the easy
pass
system
and I was actually just talking to
someone on the way in this morning that
they're getting bills for a plate that
is no longer
theirs unfortunately when that happens
and they go through and I didn't take
out the New Hampshire portion of this
but dealing with the Easy Pass and
trying to get these things rectified is
a real
hardship
my
constituency does not have the ability
to have an Easy Pass
system to have an easy path system you
have to have at least a minimum of $20
in an
account a lot of these people that $20
allows them to get to
work when you put money in an easy path
system it sits there and no one gets any
interest on their monies it's free money
for the system
and so the reason I brought this forward
is because and a lot of these people
move around a lot so they're not even
getting their bills or they're not able
to pay the fines and on top of all of
that is that if you do not have an easy
pass in your vehicle you would charge an
additional
amount so who are we hurting we're
hurting the constituency that needs us
to be looking out for them the
most and that is why I submitted this
bill and that is why I remove the
administra rative fees from being paid
in order to register your
vehicle these people that I'm
representing live from paycheck to
paycheck and have a hard time making
ends meet and in the economy that we're
in it's actually gotten
worse
so I would urge you to really delve into
this and look at this and I am open to
any
questions questions for the
representative representative who okay
yes uh representative could you describe
a little more are these problems if they
use Easy Pass on other state or in New
Hampshire um so if you do not have an
Easy Pass system and you can't afford it
and you travel into Massachusetts or
Maine you don't have any options even in
the state of New Hampshire you no longer
really have an
option because we have gone to a almost
an completely electronic
system and for a lot of these folks they
might have to travel through a toll
booth and they can't afford an Easy Pass
this is
punishing people that we're supposed to
represent and
help thank you any further
questions thank you for your testimony
oh I'm sorry
please um with the passage of this bill
do you think it would lead to abuse
people just say nothing's going to
happen why Why Pay
It representative I I thank you for that
question um there's already abuse going
on we can't
legislate stopping people from abusing
the
system and the thing is is if you abuse
it in New Hampshire we can still go
after them it's if they go travel into
another state those states can prevents
a New Hampshire citizen a New Hampshire
citizen from
registering and sell selling their
vehicle if they need the
cash thank you uh further question
please represent
pearon bone I'm sorry thank you Mr
chairman so could you could you just
walk me through this um so the person's
drive I'm thinking it happens on the
Massachusetts Turnpike is that probably
one of the situations that come up
because there's no toll I mean there's
no you it has to be an electronic
transfer on the Mass
Pike so thank you for the question
um so yes I mean I went to
Massachusetts and I still have not yet
to receive a bill to the best of my
knowledge and that was over six months
ago
now there are other times when someone
borrows a person's vehicle and and
they're unsta and that they may owe a
toll right I
mean there is a huge flaw in the way the
system works I don't know what the
answer is but this here is not the
answer how we're doing it thank you
followup question thank you Mr chair so
they still have to pay the tolls under
this bill it's just basically they they
get out they don't have to pay the
administrative
fee that is correct for new Ure citizens
and if they don't pay the toll they
still could be prevented from having the
registration approved right in New
Hampshire yes but could Mass still be
able to tell New Hampshire that there
there's an unpaid toll
no thank
you thank you further questions yes
representative
CL I noticed from the fiscal note that
they have not estimated the amount of
Revenue
that the state would lose now I
understand if if we have a scoff wall
from
Massachusetts we see them go through the
New Hampshire toll without paying we
send the notice to the state now there's
no way to enforce that so the revenue we
might have collected from Massachusetts
are
main drivers who decide not to pay our
toll goes down so in
fact there is a
there is a fiscal impact from that it
hasn't estimated here but uh do you have
any idea how many of those tolls we be
Miss as a result of this thank you for
your question if you look at the very
last page of the bill it tells you that
the department uh related collections of
$326 in fiscal year
2022 and
93,471 fiscal year
2023 and with the removal of the $50
administrative fine it was a would be a
loss of
$4,400 so
um yeah and if you notice that um there
were over a million UNP 1.6 million
unpaid
transactions and the highest ranking
States uh were New Hampshire Mass with
27% and Maine with 6% so I think that
the majority of the plate
that are having the issues are our New
Hampshire plates and our New Hampshire
citizens any further questions for the
representative seeing none thank you
thank you very
much I have a second card from H John
corkran from New Hampshire Department of
Transportation
turnpikes
good morning chairman and members of the
committee my name is John corkran I'm
the bureau administrator of a bureau of
turnpikes administrator for
nhdot um and I oppose the bill the
turnpike system operates on an
Enterprise fund where all the revenue
collected on the system must be used on
the system in fiscal year 23 we
collected 1 $1.3
million of that
$13.9 million was toll Revenue that's
cash or easy
pass with that Revenue we we I broke it
down into four categories where that
money is spent operations and
maintenance that is for the collection
of tolls cash easy passs their
violations and including our vendors um
plowing repair and drainage guard rail
Bridges U material for those repairs
mowing tree work and also our vendors
who help support us with that
work um we also category that gets spent
with that money is Debt Service and last
year we spent 28.3 million paying off
our
debt um our renewal and replacement
program is the third category this is
where we advertise our projects to keep
the system in good working order those
are like our resurfacing projects our
drainage repair project guard rail toll
plaza rehab Bridge painting and Bridge
rehabs and then the fourth category we
spend where the money goes is the
capital expansion that is also part of
the state's 10year Transportation um
plan AKA 10year plan and these projects
um are involving on the DOA Rochester a
the widening from Nashwood of Bedford um
Newington shed and also the Newton Dober
production um Dober pedestrian bike
bridge and the capital expenses for last
year was 36.7 million all the revenue is
put right back into the system to
benefit the users of the
system um the turnpike system operates
under the easy path system which
consists of 35 toll agencies in 19
States and provides a seamless and
effective and efficient way to collect
toll for instate residents and out ofate
residents um typically where you these
tolls are in Easy Pass Lanes or in open
road toll Lanes or at all electronic
tolling environment and fiscal year 23
the electronic toll system collected
110.71202012 account options you can
have a transponder account where we read
your transponder we also have a license
plate option where we read the license
plate and then we also have a 7-Day
postpay that is where somebody who goes
through the toll who doesn't have the
money they can go online and pay it
within seven days after the toll and
that is just the toll pair no other fees
are added on to
it um when the when they fail to pay and
incur several a lot of a number of
violations um the customers are faced
with suspension of vehicle registration
this is a total collection enforcement
method as known as DMV hold which has
been
effective um New Hampshire residents
face the consequence a vehicle
registration suspension for failure to
pay tolls plus residents of Maine and
mass who fail to pay New Hampshire tolls
this is due to our toll re um collection
reciprocity enforcement agreements we
have the department opposes the bill
which would eliminate our reciprocity
toll collection enforcement agreements
with massam main which have been
effective since
2011 with these agreements we are only
we are only be suspending vehicle
without these agreements we only
suspending Vehicles registrations with
New Hampshire residents and allow mass
and Maine to continue to violate on our
system these agreements are presently in
place so New Hampshire can collect tolls
from our bordering states which are also
the the states that mainly use our
facilities
um now I'd like to explain the Easy
paath System to help with understanding
of uh the fiscal note we
submitted um there's an easy path system
as I mentioned there's electronic toll
Lanes through the electronic toll Lanes
approximately 74% of the traffic going
through there have Easy Pass accounts so
we are um processing their payment
through their accounts another 177% of
them we call undefined transactions are
vehicles that go through where we don't
read a
transponder um and we often with those
we take a picture of their
plate all these transactions and images
of the plate are sent to our Easy Pass
vendor the Easy Pass vendor reviews the
plate the state the number I mean the
plate number the plate the state and the
plate type and ties that image to the
transaction in the fiscal note there was
a reference in June 2023 of having 1.6
million unpaid transactions that was for
that month in June of the unpa
transactions that went through the toll
plaza of and I'm going to try to break
that down to explain what happened to
those
transactions 43% of those transactions
became image tolls which are people who
we who didn't have their transponder in
their vehicle and we were able to charge
to their Easy Pass account through their
license plate or it could have also been
a license plate account 133% of those
got rejected those could be you know bad
images no front plate um and the weather
now we get a lot of rejects because of
the um
snow 3% paid before there was an invoice
issue that could have been through S day
to pay or they call the customer service
center before the invoice was issued and
41% of those were issued a first
invoice of those 1.6 million
transactions of the images we reviewed
the major the majority of the percent of
the um plates were from New Hampshire
there was
47% um 27 were from Mass 6% from Maine
and there were 6% from Rhode Island
Connecticut Vermont New Jersey New York
and 14% from the other states and
including
Canada for for invoicing we only request
address lookup for our registered
vehicles from the DMVs from new Hamp
from eight states it's New Hampshire
Maine Rhode Island Connecticut Vermont
New York and New
Jersey of those state of those invoices
in fiscal year 23 we issued 1.9 million
invoices
of those when you when we first issue an
in first invoice the customer has 30
days to
pay um if not paid in 30 days it goes to
a second invoice and then the customer
has another 30 days to pay that invoice
actually comes on pink paper too we're
hopeing that it stands out to them um if
they don't pay that second invoice they
have 30 we issue a violation notice and
then they have 30 days to pay the
violation
notice DMV hold which is what this law
is referred to happens when a customer
has 10 transactions at a violation
notice so they have to accumulate at
least 10 transactions at a violation
level before we can start the DMV hold
process um and what that does is it
creates a hold file for that specific
vehicle
owner um at this after that we
personally reach out to each customer
and make them an offer instead of
sending them to DMV for the suspension
they have 30 days to pay that and if
they don't pay that then they get sent
to DMV
hold uh or to DMV DMV then sends them
out a letter informing them possible
expension suspension due to the um
unpaid tolls and they got 30 days to pay
that and if they don't pay that then the
customer gets put into DMV hold which is
registration
suspension um the register owner who
goes through this they have received a
lot of notices you know you typically
get nine to 12 pieces of mail consisting
of these first second and violation
notices all the notices go to the
registration the register owner's
address that is at DMV that's where we
get all our addresses
from um in reference to the DMV hold in
fiscal year 23 we had approximately
75,7 of them some of those were
duplicate plates the same person going
through the toll plaza so which brought
us down to 7 70,000 DMV
holds um of these DMV holds
approximately 5 50,000 are New Hampshire
plates and
15,600 mass and 3,700
remain presently we are Smit in DMV
holds for Massa main about we're at a
limit of 20 per month and that's because
it's a labor effort it's not automated
with DMV which is something we like to
do with the
DMVs of those 15,000 DMV holds in um
fiscal year
23 um the total value the total amount
was around
$420,000 um our typical collection rate
is around 69% and that would equal to
,000 in our fiscal note we just noted
what was pay um in fiscal year 23 which
was the
92,000 um some of that the reason why we
aren't able to get the whole all the 318
is because we're it's limit to 20 per
month it's a manual effort so that
reduces our chance of collecting
everything but the 318 is what we
estimate we would be able to get if we
were able to go autom made
it um in Maine we had 300 3,700 DMV
holds excuse me which is approximately
about $83,000 in tolls um with a
collection rate of 69% we would get 60
$60,000 for
that in conclusion the fiscal year 23
total revenue is
$378,000 from invoice from Main and mass
invoicing violation processing that we
may not
we may not get if this DMV reciprocity
is removed a lot that money isn't a lot
of money but it does support a lot of
those programs that I mentioned
before also you can't forget too there's
33% of the total revenue from Mass and
Maine that we collect money through
their Easy Pass
accounts some of those people might find
out oh there's no more DMV hold there's
not a hammer on this they might decide
they're not going to they're going to
take their Easy Pass transponder out of
their car because it's free toll in New
Hampshire um a dis discon of this DMV
reciprocity with mass m also does not
treat New Hampshire residents compared
to our neighboring states that means New
Hampshire residents are getting
penalized for DMV hold and neighboring
states will not get
penalized um lastly to um we didn't
mention it in our fiscal note but if the
bill is passed there is some edits that
need to be in there because it
references removal of the reciprocity of
the iag that we can't remove that is
like the trans when we're collecting
transponders and we're
exchanging um transactions between the
agency we need
that um in the in the law still um that
concludes my testimony I'm happy to
answer any questions the committee may
have
um thank you uh thank you for the
testimony could I also ask It prepares
you had a a written statement would you
would you please submit a copy of that
to the clerk yes for your we can I wrote
on this can we send it wait yeah send an
EMA I think it'd be very helpful for
represent Jack yeah actually I was going
to uh raise that if you could just give
me the one they've written on that would
be great yep all
right thank you rent boy
thank you Mr chairman uh administrative
courton thank you for your testimony I
appreciate it as it relates to the
Spalding Turnpike the FB Everett and the
main line are there physical toll
collectors still employed by the
Department of
Transportation on this Spalding on the
Spalding eff Everett in the mainline
I'll even throw in I'll even throw in
hackin Hill Road because I drove it on
Sunday um the total tenants are employed
by the state of New Hampshire yes um at
they're only working 6: a.m. to 10:00 at
night and then it's AET after that and
all those facilities thank you followup
followup Mr chairman do they have the
same arrangements with the Commonwealth
of Massachusetts in the state of
Maine our toll attendants or correct no
our toll attendants to your
knowledge employed by the Commonwealth
of Massachusetts in the state of
Maine not to my know fair fair enough
follow up Mr chairman please thank
you what is the current reciprocity
agreement between the state of New
Hampshire the Commonwealth and the state
of Maine as it relates to violators for
non easy pass
users the how is how is that handled the
reciprocity is handled if the state of
Maine collects um has a person in New
Hampshire who's on their system system
who violates more than 10
transactions in violation they can send
a hold file to us requesting to put them
in suspension we review that make sure
the the images match the plate and the
transactions and then we can approve it
and then they then DMV will send them or
send that person a registration
suspension and is there a last question
there representative I have a lot of
questions on this but I I need to ask a
question to administrative Coran's
response and then I will stop thank you
Mr chairman as it relates to your your
previous
comment is that is the driver's license
immediately suspended or are they going
back to your testimony given the
appropriate time to receive the bill and
begin to
make begin to make payment to the
Department of Transportation or to the
applicable state so that they are put
back into good standing if if it's
somebody who's on New Hampshire
traveling on main turnpike you're
referencing they would get that same
letter from our New Hampshire DMV and
they'd have to they get 30 days to pay
the bill and stuff like that so they
have 30 days before their licensees is
to nonrenewal yeah okay thank you thank
you Mr chairman represent Fulon uh just
to clarify it's the vehicle registration
that's suspended not the driver's
license is that correct yes it's not the
driver
I appreciate the clarity thank you
further
question if if I could uh do we have a
similar agreement with state of
cantic no we just have reciprocity
agreements with Maine and
mass is uh not New York is this is the
state of Connecticut still a u are you
tracking how much money is lost with the
state of Connecticut is it still a
significant amount um with the state of
Connecticut no it's not a significant
amount of violations or invoice is
violation ations that we sent out there
um they might be down near under 1%
thank you any further questions yes
please represent
B would you say it be true that a person
is not
necessarily Lily required to travel a
toll road to get from point A to point B
that there are alternative non-tool
roads that one can travel and avoid
having to pay a toll at all in New
Hampshire
yes thank you any further
questions yes please uh thank you Mr
chairman there was an inference uh
before uh and testimony that it's been
difficult to get a hold of easy pass to
uh to try to rectify some of these
situations are you aware of that or do
you agree with
that um uh the Easy Pass call center
call line has a long wait time I agree
with that the DMV or like the violation
one is a little quicker but they do have
an option on the on the on the uh say
the wait time that you can put your name
and phone number there and they will
call you back with by the end of the
day okay thank you thank you thank you
any further
questions I want to thank you for
occupying most of my time I had allotted
here because I thought it was going to
be short so thank thank you for your
testimony thank
you is there anyone else that has spoken
that wishes to speak again or any new
testimony at this
point seeing none I will call to a close
hearing 1439
FM uh to the committee I apologize I
thought we'd have more on this than we
do you have a half hour break and I'll
speak with the vice chairman try and
schedule out some more of these prop
exec sessions thank
you
not
e
um late tomorrow and we can exec we were
looking to exec after after our session
tomorrow
1379 and
1253 those are all the bills you heard
last week I think it was Wednesday when
we were in here but in the event we
can't get there after session we're
considering coming in the Tuesday the
6 to exec those
items how would that fit your
schedule so we would be in here probably
probably be done by lunch unless we have
and we'd start at 10:30 so if there was
something that was rubbing one party or
the other uh there'll be time to cck us
ahead of that and if there is an issue
let's let's figure that out we can talk
later but and so that would we would
come in Tuesday for the morning for then
we'd have to come back the next day for
hearing I yeah there there's just
there's just not enough room the next
day to capture that because on the
7th um we're planning on um we have a
full schedule and we're going to we're
going to try and try and exact the bills
from
today there's that one that we didn't
actually have the hearing on also yeah
day that's scheduled for the seventh I
believe yeah and then it turns out
science told me they had a bill that
ended up with them that looked entirely
like it should have been here maybe they
just exchanged them oh he was told to
keep it so yep well we were told that as
well yeah so can't thinking a two ven us
out yeah they um so we and there there
may be problems with me you know putting
this on an Exe on the
calendar but
I I've run into a few issues with this
sort of thing this year that never seen
ever before in my life legislative life
so um we'll we'll try and work that out
today and see if that's possible so if
all if all goes well with session we're
going to dis we're going to have
executive session on all those bills if
for some reason we can't meet tomorrow I
deem it's too late um then we will exec
on the 6th okay so you can put that on
your
calendar
right yes
m
coming in and
testifying okay sorry about that go
ahead thank you Mr chairman and
honorable members of the public works
and Highway committee my name is
representative Caitlyn cab and I'm here
to introduce this bill which is
establishing a study committee relative
to alternatives for the road tool and
vehicle registration fees including
electric vehicle registration fees and
the reason behind this is I know that
there was a commission that had been
ongoing but it was more focused on road
tools and it didn't include vehicle
registrations the cost of vehicle
registrations is really becoming pretty
expensive for for many families I know
for my um Grand Highlander that I just
got which was under $50,000 car um
because it was a 20124 model I paid uh
$984 to register it this year and it
meeting last year and then because again
I bought it in 2023 as a 2024 model I'll
have to pay that again next year um and
then it the the amount kind of decreases
each year but it's just they're really
becoming quite expensive and I think I
think we need to look into some
alternatives to to see about making
those be less I think ultimately they're
the reason behind them obviously is to
pay for the upkeep of the roads and a
new car isn't causing
more wear and tear on a road certainly
than an old car is and one could argue
that perhaps you know a a a heavier
weight vehicle is going to cause more
wear and tear on a road than a smaller
car would and uh
I think it's worth looking into seeing
what we can do about this I I had
received several emails from
constituents who were concerned about
the rising costs of of uh car
registrations and I uh wanted to bring
this forward for your consideration I'm
happy to take any questions okay all
right thank you representative questions
uh yes go ahead please representative
blue thank you Mr chairman and
representative kab good to see you um
regarding your bill
on under the membership it's it's listed
as only four members do you think we
need to have a fifth member so that it's
odd if so would we contemplate another
member of the Senate or the governor's
design me
or and if you weren't prepared for that
question I apologize I actually think
that it would be okay that way I think
that there's been a lot of I think that
it's important and especially in work
like this that we we would have a
bipartisan kind of solution there and I
I would hope that it would be a solution
that everybody could agree on because
that would be the ultimate goal a lot of
my pretty much all of my bills that I
put in this year were all bipartisan I
think we need to work together to come
up with a solution and find something
that everybody can agree on because if
we can get four people to agree then we
can probably get the majority of the
house to agree as well and the same with
the Senate so I think there's something
to be said with getting everybody on a
on a committee to agree yes
please chairman and then on on the uh
the due date of November 1st 2024 do you
think that provides ample time of
roughly about six months for the
committee to to do it's due diligence to
provide a report that gives gives us
some direction of where we need to
go I do think so okay I do I'm not
looking for it to be ex you know an
extensive amount of time I
think some of these committees kind of
can go on and on and on and I'm
certainly not looking to have that that
happen and I think
that I have some of the data but I
wasn't able to kind of go through it
quickly enough which is part of the
reason for for putting in for this this
committee and I think it's it's
certainly not my wheelhouse so to speak
so I think having some people that are
more experienced in this look at it
would would be better anyway okay thank
you for your testimony and for the
record I do support the Bill thank you
Mr chairman thank you thank you
represent Bo further questions of
represent cev right is that correct
correct okay uh from the committee any
further yes go ahead please
representative
Newton thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question you mentioned in
your testimony that auto registrations
are getting extremely expensive would
this could you see this commission or
committee look into exactly what autor
restoration money is going towards
because in Rochester almost 5 million a
year goes into a slush fund it goes into
the unassigned fund balance not to fix
roads it goes into the unassigned fund
balance would you see this committee
possibly looking at that as a way to
reduce the
cost think that the committee could
could consider all alternatives to to
reduce the costs that's certainly
something worth looking into making sure
that again it is going for the purpose
that it's supposed to be purposed for so
absolutely I think looking at it is a
good idea okay thank you yes represent
Jack please uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for appearing uh would you
agree with me that house rules preclude
a committee in the second year from
lasting Beyond November
1st I believe that you are correct on
that representative thank you for
pointing that
out okay thank you represent Jack
further questions of represent koutev uh
uh from the committee any further
questions okay seeing none thank you
very much for your testimony
represent I will now call upon uh
Jessica Willcox who hasn't taken a
position on from New Hampshire Dees but
is here to serve as a resource in her
pink card so please welcome to public
works and highways Miss
Wilcox thank you chair and members of
the committee I just wanted to um my
name for the record my name is Jessica
Wilcox and I work in the mobile sources
section over at the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services and
I just wanted to share that I had been
the representative for Dees on the house
bill 412 commission that met last year
that passed during last year's
legislative session and was part of that
discussion on road to Alternative so
just wanted to be here today in case
there were any questions or if I could
be be a resource to you all as you
continue to discuss and consider these
bills thank you okay thank you for
coming and uh your testimony and being
willing to answer our questions
questions of Miss Willcox please for
members of the committee are there any
questions okay seeing none thank you
very much bu I hope you'll stick around
especially when we EXA this bill because
we may a few questions May pop up okay
thank
you um okay is there anybody else here
to testify for or against House Bill
1464 is there anybody else here present
1464 and I believe to I need to read if
anybody signed the blue sheet
representative Newman if you could pass
that up to me please we've got to get in
the habit I think of doing this uh and I
will do the best I can to remember when
I'm presiding and a
um
okay thank you Representatives Newman
Boyd and
Jack okay I do have one uh person person
signed the blue sheet and Mr Dan Bennett
from the New Hampshire Auto Dealers
Association in support of the bill House
Bill
1464 so again just we clear is anybody
else wishes to testify for or against
and if you wantan to okay anybody else
who would want to sign the blue sheet
quickly but otherwise I I only have one
person so in unless there's anybody for
or against I will close the public
hearing on House Bill 1464 thank you
very much everybody and we have some
more time before our next
hearing okay yeah oh yeah that's a good
idea
representative um I guess that's our
next hearing is not until 1:15 when we
hear House Bill 1196 so unless the chair
anybody has something else I guess
you'll have a long one
thank
you okay thank you Dan for the
candies y well there's a lot of
rules you know it all Mar here well it's
called
insc
e
be
1196 I have just a little committee uh
update here um depending I had told the
committee that I'll announce on the
floor uh if we're done at an early
enough hour this Thursday Thursday I got
this time um we
15471 14881
1253 if we're running late and we can't
do that I will announce on the floor
that we are going to meet in this room
201 on the 6th to exec those those bills
so they're going to hold off putting it
in the calendar for now if it turns out
that happens at the end of Thursday
they'll put it in the calendar
otherwise look for a notice on the
floor so with that and if there's any
questions please speak to me later or
John about that uh I would like to open
up um our 115
hearing um House Bill 1196 FN relative
request for E easements for the purpose
of laying sidewalks along class one
through five highways and I would like
to recognize the sponsor uh
representative
Eric gallager Gallagher thank you so
much please so welcome to Public Work
sir
hi I'm representative Eric Gallagher I
represent Mar County District 20 which
is conquered Ward six um it's just down
that way a little bit within walking
distance which is something that's
actually relevant to this bill since
it's about um being a pedestrian um so
um yeah I I don't have a car and thus
try to walk as many places as possible
um
so I recently um changed dentists and my
new dentist is out more on Pleasant
Street that ways so um my route for
walking there takes me um along Pleasant
Street past the state hospital grounds
and if you ever been by the state
hospital grounds before one thing you'll
notice is that there actually isn't a
sidewalk walk
along that portion of Pleasant Street
there so I got in touch with the city
councilor I knew um well now now the
mayor Byron Champlain of conquered about
why there isn't a sidewalk there
currently and apparently it's because
the state owns the
land and um that thus also owns the
telephone poles on it and
that the telephone poles would need to
be moved in order to put a sidewalk down
um and there isn't apparently isn't
currently a way
for the city to do that so um I filed
this bill to address that sort of
situation um I got in touch with n g of
the municipal Association for help with
drafting it uh so he helped provide um a
lot of the wording
um
so um yeah I forget the class Road
specifically
um that Pleasant Street there is
um along the state hospital grounds but
we included class one two three and four
um just inclusively to make sure we'd
covered all the bases um
and so uh one one bit of feedback
um I got during the drafting process the
first draft had 30 days of receiving the
request I heard that might be actually
too short to process it so um I
increased it to 90 days um which
hopefully is enough
um and
um yeah so and also hopefully um so what
while I mentioned the specific case um
in conquered that inspired this um I've
also heard of other
communities where it might be relevant
too like there was some news from the
Sea Coast I think it was Hampton or Ry
where they were trying to figure out how
to put a sidewalk along uh a state-owned
road and couldn't figure out how to do
it so I think this bill would be helpful
over there too um
so yeah I I think um this boat would be
helpful for pedestrians and that
pedestrians ship is something that we
should encourage it's good for uh
People's Health and the environment um
and uh so being being um what one
question I got is well why not just walk
on the shoulder well so that that's
that's more dangerous um being on a
sidewalk really does help um that having
that curb there to protect you from cars
that might be um varying a little bit to
the side um so yeah as a pedestrian I
would much rather be walking on a
sidewalk rather than the shoulder of the
road um so yeah hopefully this bill will
help get help us uh get more of those
built and I'll take questions now thank
you uh questions for the
representative yes representative Eaton
please I guess I shouldn't be being
specific because it's a bill that
affects the entire state
but um visualizing my mind going up
Pleasant Street and along Fruit
Street and I see sidewalks in my mind it
may not be on both sides of the road but
I thought there was a sidewalk yeah so
there is a sidewalk on one inside of the
street the thing is due to the um odd
Junction layout um at the junction of uh
Fruit Street Pleasant Street and Warren
Street with five streets there um the
side of the street that the sidewalk is
on it comes to a point there um like
this really narrow acute angle um and
you can't actually cross from that point
um there's no there's there's no
sidewalk to the tip it comes to you have
to go back down around the other side of
Warren Street to um the
nearest crosswalk which is by the high
school and then up the other side of
Warren Street again which is
um ra would is rather
inconvenient thank you thank you yes
represent thank you Mr chairman and
representative Gallagher thank you for
taking my question if these sidewalk
are eventually constructed who's going
to be responsible for the overall
maintenance and repair if necessary of
said
sidewalks um so yeah it says that in the
bill lines 14 to 15 the municipality is
responsible for any construction costs
and maintenance of the sidewalk um so
yeah that's something that the
municipality would have to uh make a
decision about when applying for it is
if they want to be responsible for the
maintenance costs or not and if they
don't want to be then presumably they
would just not apply for it okay thank
you for answer thank you thank you Mr
chairman yes please thank you chair
represent the does is the m is the
municipality on the hook for utility
relocations too you mentioned in this
case this example the uh utility
polls
um
so it's a request
for an easement um
and
um I mean I think that would be written
into the terms of the easement
um yeah
um yeah I I'm not quite sure
specifically about like terms of um
payment if that's what you mean by on
the hook for um but I think that would
fit under um being responsible for
construction costs thank you represent G
thank you representative jurus any other
questions yes please
represent I just have a simple
question have you already
tried asking the do for that
easement um not not directly um I think
well just due to
um yeah due to some of the conversations
I got started I think um that um it was
either the city of conquer or the
municipal Association may have um done
that for me and um yeah uh decided
that uh crafting this legislation would
be a Better Way Forward well we did that
up followup question represent
F we did that up in
Hillsboro
and we've been building a sidewalk now
for two
years I I just think this might already
be a
law
well I don't know I mean maybe it is
possible but the city of conquered seems
to think that it isn't and the idea here
is to reassure the city of conquer that
they do in fact have a way
forward thank you represent
vulner so I don't know if you've had
discussions with DOT but it seems like
the different class roads going to have
very different considerations a class
one road is like an interstate highway
and I could see that the do would not
want
to have pedestrians walking alongside
interstate highway and yet this I think
would require them to issue that class
two are secondary state
roads maybe similar issues class three
are Forest roads and things like
that I can't imagine that would be an
issue but why would the municipality be
involved in that class four and five are
already Municipal roads and why would
they be having to go to the state I'm
just not sure that this is a General
problem that um that this provides a
solution to um so yeah thank you for the
question um so yeah I kind of
um I kind of was over cautious in just
uh choosing the number of classes of
roads that it would apply to and I'd be
open to an amendment that
um that reduces it to just the classes
that you think are relevant if you think
that would be uh helpful in getting the
bill
passed thank you any further question U
for myself and perhaps you already uh
perhaps you already brought this in
represent I apologize if I'm asking it
twice you had a conversation with the
with the city on it did the city say if
you were to if the state was to provide
a the ease me that they would move
forward with a
proposal
um I mean not explicitly but
um basically they said you should you
should file legislation so that's what I
did and I'm assuming that in telling me
that that they were implying that if I
did then they therefore would all right
go ahead and use it thank you for your
response any further questions seeing no
further questions a representative thank
you for your testimony I'd like to bring
up um David rodrig from New Hampshire
dot
please good
afternoon good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is David rodrig and I'm the
assistant commissioner for the
Department of
Transportation the department does have
concerns with this bill as proposed um I
will will start by saying it was very
helpful to hear the spirit in which uh
the bill was proposed the area that
representative Gallagher is speaking
about is really within conquer's Urban
Compact and the Department of
Transportation I don't believe has any
re well I'm sure we don't have any
responsibility for the the maintenance
of Pleasant Street in that area um but
it's probably also a class five City
Road I need to make sure it's not a
class 4 Urban compact Road um but I
think why this area is different than a
sidewalk adjacent to our regular
highways is I believe the state's
interest in that property is the state
hospital grounds not the Department of
Transportation so I did leave Mr
Gallagher my card I'd be happy to work
with him to find the owner of that
property so that he can direct the city
to work with them on an easement if
that's what's appropriate with regard to
a law that um requires the department to
issue or consider easements from
municipalities for sidewalks um adjacent
to our state maintained roads there are
a number of issues that would be created
by that the the first issue is the
department already has either in
easement or owns the land in in fee and
we are very interested in constructing
sidewalks where municipalities are
interested in maintaining those
sidewalks in the in the future in Ean
isn't necessary I know of no State Road
on um where a municipality wanted to
install a sidewalk and maintain it that
we were not able to accommodate that if
we were in a position of having to give
the municipality an easement that would
then put a cloud on our land rights and
when we wanted to widen the road or
other things we would have the
municipality to to deal with um and that
could create some EXP events and some
issues with that so those are just a few
of my concerns but I hope that gives a
flavor and i' be happy to take any
questions thank you sir um represent
Jack uh thank you Mr chairman and thank
you uh commissioner for appearing uh
we've had bills in the past that have a
shell issue after a time limit provision
as this one does and uh can you comment
on whether you think that's
problematic time limits can be
problematic for us the depending on the
particular um Bill and
situation further questions thank you
please represent
Eon I think I know the answer but just
curious uh the area that he's talking
about is on the Pleasant Street Fruit
Street School Street that old
intersection and is there any
dual legal fee owner ship it's New
Hampshire State Route
9 that comes through on the Pleasant
Street but it's in the city compact is
Pleasant Street is there any dual
ownership dual use dual
responsibility if it is an urban compact
Road the the city's responsible to
operate maintain and reconstruct that
road um we do have some oversight in
what the city does on the urban compact
roads to make sure they don't do
anything that degrades past Federal
investments in those roads so it really
depends on some research for this
specific
segment thank you further questions of
the
committee seeing none thank you sir nice
to have you once again good to see
you all right uh is there anyone that
spoke uh that wishes to speak a second
time or member of the public that wishes
to speak before the
committee yes please representative have
a
seat just reintroduce yourself Mr
Gallagher um hi so yeah it's Eric
Gallagher again uh AMT County District
20 um
so yeah
um actually I I'm sorry I'm something
that um Mr rodri said um reminded me of
something that I had meant to say during
my main
testimony
um but yeah now now it's slipped my mind
again so sorry about that yeah no that's
quite all right representative if it
comes to you um we'll be looking to exec
on this bill next week please send it
through the committee as testimony all
right thanks i' be happy to consider it
thank you for your time thank you all uh
we will call to a
close um House Bill
1196 and our next hearing starts
in 10
minutes
here book and um I will communicate with
the governor's office and do and try and
get those in your hands very
shortly
okay time being where are we two
o'clock um House Bill 1234 FN relative
the repair of class six roads not
maintain not not maintained by
municipality and I will recognize
uh representative
pomante did I get that close
sir thank you sir for to introduce the
uh the
Bill thank you Mr chair I'm
representative Tony panti of Sandown
District 9 I'm here to introduce the
house bill 1234 relative to the repair
of class six roads not maintained by the
municipality I'll note that there are
drafting errors in House Bill 1234 as
introduced as compared to LSR 24
21780 which was
reviewed and signed off by the sponsor
representative Earth F who is unable to
repair today I understand an amendment
to correct the bill to correspond the
LSR which doesn't contain the errors has
been filed or drafted by representative
Jack this committee uh bill was put in
at the request of a constituent of
Representative Earth and that was Mr
Javi Richardson of we Mr Richardson is
here today to speak to the need to the
bill I am happy to answer any questions
though Mr R Richardson can provide more
in-depth responses and I would uh prefer
if you said uh and his questions
to thank you represent before you leave
we're going to give the committee of
course a chance anyone have any
questions for the good representative
seeing none thank you for the
introduction sir thank you very much uh
for the
committee um and I'm looking for some
guidance here perhaps uh um
representative Jack
where uh the amendment was prepared to
move this could you speak to your
amendment that you brought forward uh
thank you Mr chairman uh I have
Amendment uh
20208 H and the effect of the amendment
is to uh restore the text private that
was inadvertently deleted from the as
introduced so throughout the text of
this code section uh it says private or
class six uh so it it normalizes the
treatment of private roads that we
already had in statute and adds on the
same treatment for class six roads and
then uh on line 10 uh there's a slight
change uh 229 colon 5 is where all of
the classes are defined and it it
changes it so that 2 that uh it does not
apply to class 1 through five but does
apply to class six so if there's if
that's clear i' I'd be happy to take any
questions if if that's unclear excuse me
Mr chairman I move we accept the
amendment uh one
seconded motion motion motion to accept
the
amendment um
0208 has been made and seconded point of
order Mr chairman we're not on Executive
session so it's not clear that that is
in order at this
time okay okay we will resend we resend
the motion I thank you for thatw my
motion okay thank you for that
correction thank you um we will um we
will move forward to further
testimony um and I
will uh call on Harvey Richardson
first and you have five minutes is what
you're
proposing welcome to Public
Works uh thank you all uh if I'm a
little nervous I apologize uh name it
Harvey Richardson my residence is in
Hollis New Hampshire uh but I'm here
today in my capacity as the treasurer of
the East Shore Drive Road
Association uh in wear that's along
Horus
Lake uh we're probably unique
in uh class six roads in that we have 61
residences on that road that's just
under a mile
long uh and we maintain that road uh
year
round uh but then all across the state
there are uh many class six roads uh
some having like ours being Lake roads
uh with a good number of residences and
of course others are nothing more than a
snowmobile trail this time of
year
uh so uh we have a road Association
voluntary uh nonprofit
and we collect dues and uh maintain the
road grading it in the summer and uh
plowing it and sanding it in the
winter uh collecting dues to do that my
budget is over $1,000 a year uh is
totally
voluntary which for most of the folks
their neighborly and and they pay their
dues uh I have some residents who flat
out refuse
and there is absolutely nothing we can
do about that so uh it's it's unfair it
raises the rate for everyone who does
volunteer uh and the intent in asking Mr
representative Earth to uh file this
bill was to give us an ability to
uh uh file a civil action against people
who
aren't uh paying but civil action I'm
kind of implying putting a mechanic lean
on the
property uh it was never our intent
to hijack the former law about uh
private roads I used that as a model
when uh representative Earth F asked me
to uh write something
up and gave that uh to him last fall and
somewhere in the translation we wound up
with with this confusion so uh I felt it
was probably cleaner to have a separate
bill just for class six roads being
there's some definite Nuance difference
between private roads and class six
roads but uh if it can be accomplished
with uh the two being on the same bill
we have no objection to
that
uh I think that's uh the main points
that uh that I have uh obviously I'll
take questions if folks have
them thank you Mr richon questions from
the committee represent Jack uh thank
you Mr chairman thank you for appearing
uh I have I have two questions uh the
original bill was brought because people
were having difficulty getting certain
types of mortgages on a private road
that didn't have a maintenance agreement
uh are you experiencing that at all on
the class six
roads uh I've asked a real a excuse me a
mortgage broker I know uh and to date
they have not found anything uh
personally I would expect uh Insurance
to be more of an issue but uh again I
haven't uh researched that in
depth thank you followup question R and
and thank you again uh normally you
cannot get a building permit on a class
on on a the fire department will not
Grant uh so presumably this started out
as a class five Road and got built on
and then became a class six road is that
the normal progression how this could
happen I'm really not sure uh
my uh the lake we're on Horus lake is a
man-made lake uh I believe it was the
30s or 40s that it was uh
created uh I would expect that the road
was put in uh and handed over to the
town uh at that point
uh and you know as many uh Lakes back
then it were what we all called camps uh
along there and nobody worried too much
about it but uh it is the town-owned uh
it's a separate strip none of our uh
residential Deeds make any reference to
it and again uh not like a private road
there is nothing in our Deeds uh talking
about about Road dues or anything of
that
nature I don't did I answer your
question thank you further questions Mr
richson yes
represent so Devil's Advocate um I'm in
the town of Stoddard and we have what
used to be a Town Road became a class
six road goes between a town road and a
state
highway there are
three
residences on that class last six
section uh none of which are used year
round but according to the verbiage of
this bill if one
person decides they want year- round
access and easy access non four-wheel
drive
access they would be able to force the
others into paying to make that road
navigable year round and last I checked
um numbers for that one road I'm
thinking of they were talking in excess
of $100,000 which would essentially
place a couple of those properties at
road maintenance more than the value of
their
dwelling
um is this an individual
scenario trying to is this a bill trying
to fix one individual scenario that can
create a Jeopardy throughout the state
that certainly wasn't our
intent uh obviously every situation is
unique
uh we get our one mile long road uh
plowed for about $7,000 a year uh if
suddenly it were to be paved I can see
where that would be $100,000 or well
north of that uh
but I suppose it's a
possibility thank thank you any other
further
questions seeing none thank you sir oh
I'm sorry go right
ahead a question
first please so I'm just asking this so
everybody who uh lives on this road is
part of the
association
is that correct yes can I follow yes go
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question so doesn't
that that's the way it is right now but
some of the members of this group are
not paying their dues is that the
situation yes I should be clear the the
association is voluntary
nonprofit
uh when I bought the property I didn't
need to sign on to the association I
just
voluntarily do so so uh I'm giving you a
wishy-washy answer if everyone everybody
on the road is a
member
uh I'm I'm sorry so not every not every
person is a member that lives on this
road of the
association again I'm not I really don't
know how to answer answer that the the
association
exists uh we meet annually we have uh
members but whether or not all right I
didn't mean confusion ask Secretary of
St we are a uh nonprofit we're
registered with the state thank you was
there a further question repres Bel so I
guess the final question is so basically
if somebody buys into this this area
they're forced to join this Association
there's because if
they or they're forced to actually have
to pay for this maintenance of the Road
H they are not that that's our problem
is we have no I'm sorry just to clarify
if this bill passes wouldn't that be the
case effectively yes okay thank you okay
thank you represent Boyd do you have a
question yeah and I I thank my my good
colleague from started for raising the
issue I work as a as a real estate title
examiner and one of the things that I've
seen specifically in Carrol County in
Grafton county is that people that are
choosing to build on a class six roadway
will enter into a road maintenance
agreement or they get the building
permit and they accept responsibility
with the fact that the road is not going
to be maintained for use and that they
and that's that's the kind kind of the
quit Pro qu we'll give you the building
permit we don't take care of the road so
there is a remedy out there that certain
min muncipalities can use with people
choosing to build on a class six road
that municipalities are not going to be
responsible for maintaining the road so
I just wanted to amplify that to to the
Comm that's good uh further
questions seeing none thank you
sir I'd like to
recognize
U Brian um I can never pronounce
you thank you
please
thank you Mr chairman members of the
Public
Works um I actually have checked off
that I was I am opposed to um what is
provided to you and hb1
1234 uh and the reason is very very
simply um the crossout of private roads
and if you would indulge me I would just
like to give you a little bit of a
history as to why this wording had come
to be please um so from 2010 to 2020 I
was a State
Rep um and this language here basically
took me three years to get
through uh and finally passed in 2019
and one of the reasons why it took so
long it was very confusing because I I'm
talking about private roads when the
issue that I was trying to solve was
Finance ING with Fanny May and Freddy
Mack on private roads that don't have a
maintenance agreement in place so we all
know that we have a housing shortage and
unemployment is we have we have
employment issues and
um by um this new bill taking out the
word private roads doesn't codify the
the the maintenance agreement that's
caught in statute right now um I can
tell you uh I'm also a real estate agent
so
I can tell you that once this pass
finally passed the real estate agents
were uh extremely appreciative that this
passed and I'll give you a reason why in
the old days you would go onto a private
road look at a house the buyers would
want to buy purchase but there was no
maintenance agreement with anybody on
that road so what would happen is these
real estate agents would actually
believe it or not go knock on
everybody's door and say would you sign
this maintenance agreement
so these people can buy this house and
if one resident said no that deal was
gone so it it seemed to be more and more
common over time that you know someone
didn't want to deal with the maintenance
agreement and so
anyway the fix for us as real estate
agents was to codify this into law and
um that's what we did with the with the
wording so when I saw this uh online
where where um representative Earth um
took out private road I was a little bit
taken aack because a took me three years
to to get it past um but B I didn't want
to go back to the old days where um
people were losing Housing Opportunity
and that's the name of the I that's the
the end of the game right there it's
affordability we have an affordability
issue here now um it's not getting any
better um housing is is critical um less
firsttime homey buyers can buy and um
and it's affecting our economy it's
affecting a lot of um people that are
looking for help so that's the only
reason why I'm opposed to it I'm not
opposed to anything any other part of it
if you want to deal with the class six
that's fine I'm not opposed to that I'm
just I want to make sure that Fanny May
and Freddy Mack still have this de facto
um maintenance agreement codified in
State Statute so that's where I'm coming
from so um with that I we have Happ to
answer any questions good representative
Jack and then thank you Mr chairman and
I thank the former representative we
worked a long time on that bill uh can
we clarify your position on the as
amended yes oh I'm sorry I should have
brought that up um I I did was able
representative Jack U was able to let me
see the amendment that he is going to
introduce uh and I'm happy with that
that that works because it doesn't take
out the word private it doesn't affect
Fanny May or Freddy Mack financing so
like I said I have no issues with
anything else in the in that proposed
bill um I just want to make sure that
you know the real estate agents
are able to still sell on private roads
because it's important thank you
represent Faulkner
please okay thank you any other further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Mr
J I struggled to remember whether you're
still a representative or not but now I
know that you're a commissioner so yeah
all right thank you for that um I
have Jason Jason
sock New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association um asking for a few minutes
in in opposition of the
bill well good afternoon I'm Jason stock
with the New Hampshire timber land
Owners Association and I appreciate the
opportunity to come and
testify to you today we are opposed to
House Bill 1 two 3 4 um our land our
Members Own and or manage about a
million Acres across the state of New
Hampshire um and a lot of this land is
accessible via class six
roads um as you had heard earlier from
representative Boyd some of these roads
have residences some of them don't
sometimes the land owners live on it
sometimes you know they are one of those
residences and sometimes they're not and
so when we looked at this piece of
legislation and and we too were involved
in the whole the the original debate on
on private roads
earlier um but when we looked at this
legislation in this proposal there were
a couple things that really just jumped
out at us um the term contribute
equitably what does that
mean number of trips um the gross
vehicle weight if I have a if I live on
a class six Road and I have a wood lot
and I'm going to do a Timber
Harvest am I now going to be is my
Equitable contribution go up that year
that I'm doing a Timber sale does it get
adjusted um that was one piece is it the
number of feet on the road um does that
indic would that be an indication I have
a residence and then again I have a 100
acres and now they look at my my
Frontage is that quote cons considered
Equitable um that was one thing that
really jumped out the other and as you
had heard you know
the well let me back up the other thing
that really created a a concern for us
was some of the definitions and in
paragraph Roman 1 they talk about
residences enjoying Jo a common benefit
and then you drop down to line nine um
you're talking about a budding and
whether you directly or
indirectly I have a piece of property my
residents that that a butts a class six
road on the along the back side of
it and I may live on a class five road
on the other side of that property but I
ABD it am I affected by this am I in the
soup on this
I have a property that I do have a
residential property that abuts it is
that now and again if I do a Timber sale
um I I cut some wood and I have trucks
coming and going is that would I now how
would that apply to me so that was the
other piece that kind of jumped out at
us is saying all right what what exactly
does this does how does that does that
uh affect us the other piece and I think
as you heard that the sponsor is they're
they have a a a voluntary it sounds like
they have a voluntary Association and
they're having a hard time getting
everyone to Annie upd and so what better
way then let's pass a law and require
this assoc these Association members to
anti up dues and Andor create a civil
action against them if I guess if they
don't pay their dues to us that seemed a
little
heavy-handed um the other and then
fundamentally what we're talking about
here is taking private money and putting
it into a public asset a class six road
is a Town Road it's it's an odd duck
town has no uh you know obligation to to
repair it maintain it but it's still a
town right of way when we go to do a
Timber sale or we go to access a
property and we're going to use a class
six Road and we have to we have to we
have to do some updates to it we we are
obligated to go to the town the
selectman or the road agent and present
what we're going to do and they have to
approve it if we monkey or touch that
road without that approval that's a
violation of of existing law and what
we're talking about here is creating
kind of this other type of class six
Road where you have private money going
in and it sounds like on a regular basis
maintaining and doing maintenance on a
on a on a public
asset
um there is a process if if you have a a
class six Road and you have a bunch of
residences that that live on it which
sounds like this may be a a unique case
there is a process to get that road
designated a private road um it happens
not frequently but it does happen um and
so there is a process already in place
in which case existing law as we' see
quite clearly in the bill there's a
mechanism there so get it
designated get it designated a private
road um have your
Association you know get out the vote at
town meeting get it designated a private
road and at that point you have a
vehicle already in law to address your
your your
issue um
and then the last thing is there were
some questions and I think
representative Boyd had mentioned this
building on a class six Road there are
there are waivers that get signed there
is a process um and the other thing
that's worth noting is if someone does
build on a class six Road you know
that's you know they build on it they go
into it with their eyes wide open this
is what is expected for services is this
is what I can expect and so there is a
process there's transparency there and I
would I would dare say that the the the
value the the the value of that home or
residence reflects that if I have a and
and I just had this discussion on a bill
in the Senate if I have two identical
homes one is on a class six Road and
then I have another which is on a
maintained road with trash pickup snow
plowing from the town and my classic
Road I'm kind of on my own my sales
values are going to differ the Market's
working the market takes care of this um
so again I I don't we don't believe this
bill is necessary we see it as kind of
opening up the door to a lot of
potential
litigation um someone gets grumpy about
you
know neighbors fighting neighbors over
who's going to maintain the road you
drove during mud season and you weren't
supposed to do that and I'm going to
bring a civil action against you to fix
those ruts we just see it we just see
and again all of this is taking place on
a public right away so for us don't we
we we urge you there other vote itl on
this there are mechanisms already in
place for this particular situation to
address it they can go ahead get it
designated private and they can raise
all the do money Do's money they want
and fix it but to take every class six
road that has a residence on it and
quite as you as came out Force those
residences into an agreement I I just
don't think that's right and and nor I
shouldn't say me the associ nhtoa thank
you chairman makoni for your Indulgence
and I'd be happy to try and answer some
questions thank you um
represent as you stated there's a place
in law to to uh use The Ballot Box and
turn those roads into a private road if
they're doing a good enough job with
maintenance there's also a unability in
law to turn it into a public road again
as well correct you are
correct F further questions yes
represent
vulner wh this in the form of a question
then do you recall that we had this
original Bill several years ago we had
extensive negotiations over essenti
every single word in the in the
bill and
um in in in in particular there was a
concern about the timber
owners and the words selected here I
think everyone agreed at the
time took the logging operations off the
hook there was no responsibility it's
only for residential users so is there
has there been any experience that that
hasn't worked the way people people
expected it to on private
roads thank you for your question I've
not I have not gotten any feedback I
will admit not a lot of wood I think a
heck of a lot more wood gets cut and
harvested and transported over class six
roads than than private roads I would
again you go particularly some of these
rural parts of the state you look at
these Town maps and you'll see roads a
spiderweb of roads and a lot of them are
class six roads uh as opposed to private
roads so we did a lot of negotiation I
remember working very closely with you
on that and at the end of the day we we
held our nose and we we we were we were
helpers and we went along with this
because we recognized there was this
this problem and that was The Fanny May
Freddy Mack F uh issue and we said all
right we're not not dealing with the
Fanny May Freddy Mack issue this time
we're dealing with some folks that are
in association that say I don't want to
pay little different thank you thank you
any further questions Mr St
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question I'd like to give
you a scenario and give me your best
guess of how it would work let's say
there's a class six Road that's a mile
long with there's two people that live
on it one lives at the
End by the road that is
maintained the other person lives at the
other and a mile
away there's only two people that live
on that road how would you explain how
this law would they would do the
equitableness of that law and how would
that work without them shooting each
other let's not resort to let's not
resort to let's not resort to violence
you you you're you're you're you're
highlighting one of my my key points is
just this as drafted how do you
determine that that question of
equitability I may drive 50 feet on it
to get out to the the main Highway a
state
road and the other residence drives 500
yards why on this bill this bill what is
equitable how do you determine that and
if I'm that 50 foot person say why am I
going to be forced into an agreement to
maintain what could could be viewed as
this basically this individual's
driveway that goes 500 yards back I
again it's for
us it's it's a public
RightWay and you know that 500 yard home
when that was built and or sold they
knew what they were getting when they
got it you were on a class six Road man
that's your
responsibility okay thank you any U any
further questions seeing none thank you
before I take the final speaker Mr
Johnson I just want to say if you're
here for House Bill 1631 we're going to
be a few minutes before we get there Mr
Johnson welcome to Public Works you
represent the Farm Bureau and asked for
three minutes and you are a opposing the
Bill thank
you thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record Rob Johnson
representing the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau as a federation's policy
director and yes we we we are opposed um
very similar to Mr stock uh few years
back um we worked uh very closely with
the Timberland owners and with the
former representative from Derry uh on
on the private w a bill as he said it
was a three-year process uh we spent
many hours at my office trying to trying
to iron out in the iron out things in
the end we we we kind of we I'd say held
our nose and went along uh but as been
pointed out by by representative jacked
earlier and others that that was Rel uh
the purpose of that bill is access to
financing and and uh we could see it uh
and this is different as Mr stalk has
pointed out this class six roads are
public ways and you're you're asking
these individuals who who would be
required to um put put their resources
towards a onto a public way and and it
was why it was not included in the the
uh when the the private way Bill became
lot that was that was understood and and
why we didn't the other thing I'd like
to point out and I guess probably like
everything I'm going to say has already
been touched on one way or another but
when when the uh land owners on these
class six roads uh purchased their
property they knew the
deal they certainly should have if they
didn't I think it's it's it's that it's
that simple uh and and I I'll try to
touch on a a a question or two
representative faulon your experience
and I can just tell you a personal one
or more relative to the private way but
my my family owns a a cottage on
Northwood Lake that something my uh my
my dad and my aunt purchased 1950 is and
um it's always been voluntary we
contributed to maintenance of the road
and if you drive down the road it's
about half a mile and we're the we're
basically the second Cottage and then
the road goes on for a couple miles and
my my family it's a a summer Cottage
it's not winter rise we we we we like it
when it snows and it's not plow because
then we're we're a little bit more
comfortable because it it prohibits
access from people to get in and but now
we are I believe the only summer
C just
press I believe every other Cottage in
the 20 somewhat on that Shore are now
winterized where there are full-time
residences and uh we have not uh
contributed to the the uh have been
contributing to the the the fund for the
years way back we we my family
contributed quite a bit we actually
built built uh brought in some some uh
um material and did a lot of work um but
since it's been uh the others a fulltime
we we feel like well we're only using it
a short portion we're right at the
beginning but we have been threatened
with with the they' show with the new
law and said hey if you don't contribute
we're gonna and and we it's just hasn't
been worth it we we we have contributed
though we still don't think we should be
have to contribute to the amount the the
others uh do so just it gives you a
little bit of an idea what
um and I guess I will uh I'll I'll leave
my testimony that appreciate your time
and attention as always thank you sir
any questions for Mr
Johnson thank you for your testimony did
you say you had written testimony okay
thank you all right uh is there anyone
that testified previously wishes to
speak again
uh excuse me Mr chairman before we close
the hearing blue
sheets thank you is there is there uh a
blue
sheet okay would you mind sending that
along re s
Newman John that was a nice
catch do you have a question also Mr
please yes and Mr chairman could I um
ask a followup question to Mr Richardson
who had previously
testified did I closed it I didn't close
okay yes please go ahead
yeah just restate your name
please name is Harvey
Richardson with the East Shore Drive
Road Association I'm the treasurer for
them Mr Richardson my question to I
guess to the best of your knowledge any
of the 61 residents that are there I'm I
have have some people transferred their
property over the years
resold and do you have any awareness of
if they had any issues when they were
selling as to financing and did any
mortgage lender get interested in what
the deal was with the road uh to the
best of my knowledge uh that has not
been an issue with mortgage
people uh recently we do try to make uh
the representing realtor the listing
agent aware that we have this
Association and they pass that on
to uh prospective homeowners and new
property owners have all uh been paying
but it's again it's continuing
voluntarily and and just to thank you is
there a followup question yes and I made
a note but there is nothing in the
deeded information for any of the
properties about this it's just an an a
gentlemen's
agreement yes that's correct and and
that's our challenge uh where uh every
piece of road down to a class six that
people live
on there's a method to collect
payment uh to maintain the road but uh
those of us on this class six we have no
method to enforce that and that was one
of the main concerns here thank you
thank you are there any further
questions seeing none uh on the blue
sheet uh the only people that have
signed the blue sheet are the speakers
uh that you've heard from and they're
showing two for and two against um with
that I will pull to a close House Bill
FN and as we can shift chairs we'll move
on to our last hearing of the
day Johnny are you going to stay you
want stay and run and I I signed the
blue sheet but
that's okay sounds good so I'll leave
you in charge
okay
okay just give me a moment John sure
abely
I've gotta fill out a pink
card okay thank you very much you're
back okay
great okay all right yeah I think it's
fine and I'm a sponsor long as we don't
speak or ask
questions
this where we bring out the hard
questions yeah
absolutely motion to
adjourn okay thank you
Mark trouble with this I will now open
the hearing on House Bill
1631 uh and this is uh extending the
commission on the revenue Alternatives
the road toll and I will now call upon
uh the Bill's Prime sponsor
representative mark mcon
welome thank you uh Mr chairman um
illustrious members of this wonderful
powerful committee I uh I sit before you
and uh ask for your attention at least
momentarily I for the record my name is
Mark makoni I represent the good people
of Carol 8 in Carol
County um I have had the pleasure of
chairing this commission um over the
last two
years uh it's relative to extending the
commission study Revenue alternatives to
the road
toll um it won't come as um as much of a
surprise to this committee uh but the
funding that we're receiving on a
continual basis is uh is mostly tied to
the federal and the state road toll uh
in the the feds I believe have not
raised that
contribution in more than 16 years it
might be more than that and there's a
reluctance by the state uh ever to
increase our um our fees on our gas for
more
income the second big issue is so we
we've got this small pot of money that
doesn't have a chance to grow uh the
second is we have Federal mandates to
make cars and trucks more more efficient
all of the time and when we do that um
we are buying less gasoline and Diesel
and when we buy less our contribution
again is less we then have the
introduction of electric vehicles which
um EVS um have until just I believe last
year are now contributing on their
registration fee for their use of the
roads so we we have an issue
that is just getting harder and harder
we have I I cannot tell you next to this
committee's membership how proud I am of
the commission members uh everyone comes
in sits down and uh and we're digging in
trying to find a way forward there there
there must be a better method to fund
our roads and our bridges and our issue
to date on this commission is it started
with a piece of legislation and and do
out to report uh our findings by the end
of the year but by the time the first
year rolled around by the time the
governor um um put his signature on the
bill uh we met only two times the next
year we thought we were doing wonderful
we thought it was going to be
fast-tracked and it was going to be
brought forward in a much quicker Manner
and again uh we ended up uh only getting
uh meeting officially we were asked not
to meet over the summer which brought us
into September and we met in Earnest
every couple weeks and uh filed our
report but we're we're not making
Headway so the the 1631 before you is to
enact that commission one more time and
I believe it runs us out for at least
three years and it is our hope at the
end of that period um and hoping that
there's
possibly a federal solution we keep
saying that this should probably be a a
federal issue uh that we will make
greater progress for the for the uh
motoring public in our state so it's the
same commission uh we it looks like we
are going to there's appointments but I
have some assurances that many of our
members are hoping to be uh
reappointed um and um I would hope that
you would support this and uh I'm happy
to take any questions if there are so
thank mononi any questions of
Representative Cony yes representative
falia
please your Committee in the past ever
considered the weight of vehicles as a
method of
determining what they PID thank you
thank you and I and i' I've had the I've
had the pleasure of some education on
this matter
matter by yourself and I and
conversations and and I I believe your
question has Merit and should be
considered
you uh further questions of
representative mcon from the commission
uh represent vone please thank you and
thank you for uh taking my question so
we earlier heard
1464 could you just help me we have this
bill Bill too but I'm seeing a
tremendous amount of overlap thank you
um when we were waiting to uh press an
LSR uh for the continuation of the
commission and was it what was the
number again representative
14 1464 if that's okay M
1464 um many many members of the
commission actually thought that someone
had um had brought forward our
legislation going forward but it appears
to be a different Mission than what we
have and I I think we will have
conversation going forward Public Works
and if perhaps maybe some of that could
be incorporated into this
commission represent Farner
please thank you representative one of
the concerns that I had expressed in the
previous legislation was whether we're
looking just at methods for collecting
money to support the road
system but that uh we should also be
looking at what the what the volume of
those needs are projecting down the road
what what uh dollar amount do we need to
maintain our road system uh in a manner
in a safe manner in a manner that we
expected to be uh provide service to
their people and then use that to help
determine how much and what kind of uh
mechanisms might
might work are we still looking at that
long-term need or was it focusing have
you been focusing mainly
on the method for
collecting uh thank you representative
an excellent
question I'm not sure how to answer the
question the um the Char the the charge
is is how we are going to uh maintain
our roadways
and I I would suspect that your question
is is part of our mission it's it's how
much money is needed to to maintain the
uh the transportation system in good
repair but I I've never I've never
thought I've never thought in the terms
of your question and I'll spend some
time but I don't have an answer for
you
further questions of represent mononi
from the committee further questions I
see no further questions thank you
representa m thank
you thank you chair and members sorry
committee all
right yes thank you chair members of the
commit go ahead okay sorry about that no
no worries um for the record I'm Jessica
Wilcox I'm the mobile sources supervisor
over at the Department of Environmental
Services and I was actually a appointee
to that hp412 commission from uh the
prior legislative year and was part of
the discussion that took place and just
ultimately want to um say that we would
be happy to continue that discussion and
I'm here today just as a resource to you
all and certainly feel free to reach out
to me at any time with any questions um
even following this but you know
ultimately just we're here to continue
the discussion if this bill moves
forward thank you so much okay thank uh
for any questions of Miss Wilcox for
members of the committee are there any
questions okay yes represent falie
please you you were run as commune in
the
past was there a lot of
attention on the quality of construction
of the roads to begin
with I don't know that we delved into
that aspect thank you for the question
um maybe something that we could
consider if a another commission came
about it's certainly a critical part
yeah thank
you okay okay thank you represent foli
Miss W Cox any other questions any other
questions of Miss WL Cox okay thank you
seeing none thank you very much for
coming in thank you um okay are are
there any other PE uh people who here
today who wish to testify for or against
House Bill
1631 anybody else here today testify or
testify again
okay okay yes absolutely could represent
Newman again could you grab the blue
sheet please and send it up our way so I
can read who signed in
please okay thank
you
all right okay thank you represent Jack
okay the signes include representative
John cluer in favor of the bill
representative Josh Uka against the bill
and Bob Scully of the New Hampshire
Motor Transport Association in favor of
the bill and that's it there were three
people signed in all right again thank
you all right I will now close the
public hearing on House Bill
1631 thank
you
see you on the floor for session and
then depending on how the day proceeds
we'll uh be back here either to exec
that day or on the following Tuesday and
so if I could see the Democrats for no
more than half an hour and then I'll
give you the day off tomorrow if you
come up and give me half an hour uh it's
room 403 it's a house meeting
room